since it was rolled out in 2011 the VW
up has developed into a popular
companion for the city and the country
it's compact size and maneuverability
are its identifying traits with the
natural gas variant of the Eco up the
mini car shows its thrifty side
the equal Manawa Schaefer says little
distinguishes the ego up from its
brothers as you notice when driving it
has a little less power than the 1 litre
gasoline engine but in daily usage
that's not noticeable it's just as
maneuverable as the other models - but
those expecting a great leap forward and
sportiness from the Eco up won't find it
it needs sixteen point three seconds to
accelerate from zero to 100 kilometres
an hour no wonder since under the hood
is only a 50 kilowatt engine that
doesn't reach its maximum torque of 90
Newton meters until it produces 3000
revs the up has an environmentally
friendly engine for an affordable price
of just under 13,000 euros in Germany in
this car the gas pump is the source of
joy fueling up is child's play the inlet
pipes for gasoline and natural gas are
next to each other
the natural gas tank holds 11 kilograms
enough for around 300 kilometers next to
it the 10 liter gasoline tank
[Music]
amano motel says the Eco up has to
reserve gasoline tank but it's mostly
untouched when it's colder than 10 below
zero Celsius or the driver had just
pumped in natural gas than the gasoline
engine will ignite first after a short
while the natural gas tension takes over
the only thing the driver notices
something aged needle shifts from the
gasoline area to the natural gas
indicator not fundamental eyes in the
net gospel I funded the Eco up is
especially popular in Italy in 2016
about one third of the up sold had
natural gas engines and Germany far
fewer ups drive with natural gas only
around 3% weak infrastructure is
certainly a reason only 900 of Germany's
14,500 gas stations sell natural gas
[Music]
after the facelifted underwent last year
the outer appearance of the up has
become more individualistic from the
bumper through the headlights with LED
daytime running lights to the side
mirrors with integrated flashing lights
the whole design has been sharpened or
redone there are also new exterior
colors contrasting roof colors exterior
stickers and colored rims to choose from
avoid here emmanuel tells us that even
though the natural gas tank is below the
trunk it still has lots of space for a
city car
[Music]
the center console has an optional
smartphone integration plug in the
device or connect via bluetooth and the
Volkswagen app turns the smartphone into
an infotainment system with a navigation
function and onboard computer the seats
with integrated headrests are modern and
upbeat - yeah amano says the Eco up
doesn't claim to be a race car but it's
great for the environment and your
wallet with 300 miles driving range for
about 11 euros most gas and diesel
vehicles can't hope to compete with that
you do have to make frequent trips to
the recharging station and natural gas
isn't available at all service stations
in Germany it's a shame that this
environmentally friendly alternative
isn't getting more attention
[Music]